alors l'un des hauts lieux de
restauration d'intelligence et à
parisienne céline oui selon alain turban
sûrement et ça depuis très longtemps vu
caen et bien moi alors bien obligé je
parle un peu en historien je pense que
c'est depuis les hydropathes 1
c'est-à-dire en 10h02 les années 1880 85
ce sont les premiers les premiers
clients de l'ip littéraire et puis après
moi je crois je n'ai jamais
malheureusement je n'ai jamais pu
réussir en avoir la certitude
enfin on peut on peut penser que
verlaine est venu s'asseoir sur sur la
baule estinnes de de cette brasserie qui
s'appelait encore brasserie des bords du
rhin
et puis après il ya eu jarry a eu à
paris à une équipe phare médias il ya eu
toute l'équipe du vieux colombier avec
copeaux jouvet tous les acteurs et tous
les auteurs alors pourquoi pourquoi dans
cette brasserie dans cette brasserie
autant d'écrivains sont venus c'est pour
la choucroute ses polars en baltique où
c'est pour le snobisme au début au début
c'est pour la bière et la choucroute
monsieur hallyday avait apporté et c'est
atassi 1 qui arrive aident et qui
voulait pas être allemand et qui veut
qu'il veut s'établir en 1800 en 1881 bon
alors il venait il est pour ca puis
après j'ai le quartier des ministères
ses alliés et les hauts fonctionnaires
sont venus et puis les aux arts les gens
des beaux-arts et puis après on a dit
mme elie pourquoi c'est peut-être sur
les patrons quand suis moi je pense que
c'est les clients qui ont failli parce
que c'est les gens qui avaient envie de
se retrouver ensemble
oui mais là comme à payer les hommes
politiques qui vont tous mourir et
pourquoi les actuels de tradition et
maintenant corps lors vous citez un
grand nombre d'écrivains jacques laurent
et bien d'autres qui sont des familles
et bien sûr mais je crois alors que
aussi des écrivains viennent là c'est
pas seulement pour régler des affaires
ils viennent même assez peu pour régler
leurs affaires d'édition s'ils viennent
c'est pour rencontrer d'autres gens et
des gens qui nous justement ne sont pas
forcément de la profession ils ont parce
qu'ils censurent des rencontres et des
hommes politiques ou des acteurs ou des
who des journalistes ils viennent aussi
parce que c'est joli cadre et puis il ya
quelques été vite dit c'était pourquoi
ça marche lips est un théâtre comme moi
moi je m'ennuie dans les restaurants moi
j'ai pas une liste de bonne bouffe je
mange je m'ennuie dans les restaurants
mais chez dix chats paillaugue aller j'y
vais pour
c'est une fête c'est un théâtre - quand
je vais chez lipp je ne sais pas la
pièce que je vais voir chez lipp
je ne sais même pas les acteurs qui
seront là mais vous êtes sûr qu'il ya
des acteurs ab je suis sûr qu'il ya des
acteurs et je suis sûr à une pièce c'est
parmi les acteurs il y aura une pièce et
je suis sûr qu'il y aura il y aura un
metteur en scène extraordinaire gras le
père case avec son carton qui va
justement à propos puisque vous avez
étudié si bien brasserie lipp
est-ce que vous avez compris le système
de monsieur 15 avec qui n'a pas le plan
de la chose sauf dans la tête et qui
peut vous dire instantanément dans dix
minutes dans un quart d'heure dans une
heure quelle est la marque d'un gars
comme ancien directeur des hautes études
possibles évident mais c'est parce que
c'est coûteux la clé c'est la cc lacq
l'esa de la philosophie 15e dans la
pièce et alors qu'elle est la clique et
bien et bien la clé cd ont quoi tête
expliqué sa pieuvre on parle alors par
la règle des possibles il ya très
longtemps et c'est le père ça c'est
clair marcellin caze cave à vin tessin
la règle est possible c'est qu'il faut
fait rentrer le plus de gens possible
mais attention pas n'importe qui des
gens possible en les faisant manger le
plus rapidement possible en avec le
personnel le plus léger possible avec
l'espoir qu'ils reviennent pas du tout
et tout est alors il me fait passer bien
des choses que l'on apprend qu'une autre
que robert sabatier a que du sa femme
chez lipp que malraux a fêté son prix
goncourt ouvrier chez lipp
enfin bref il ya plein d une vraie
hemingway & cie hemingway qui a écrit
jean paris est une fête a écrit un joli
un joli passage sur le cervin moulin et
la fin de tribu ayant ordonné une
anthologie
littérature libyenne extraites de
certains livres notamment le dernier
jacques laurent où il ya trois quatre
pages sur le rythme des libyens et vous
savez s'il a fait plus plaisir dans ce
livre quand j'ai au corps demande en
quête
quand j'ai découvert que marcel proust
avait été fait et qui surtout qu'il
avait fait venir avant d'aller chez lipp
il avait fait venir il avait envoyé il
avait envoyé le le chauffeur le mari de
sa fidèle d'un fidèle servante chercher
sur les conseils sur les conseils de ses
amis envoyé chercher une bouteille de
bière fraîche je suis dit tu habites
affaire là boulevard haussmann et de
temps en temps il à se faire cherchez
pas ce que c'était la meilleure guerre
de paris